so the students in the audience know who
I am I'm Nick Christie Blake and I'm the
the chair of frontiers of science for
fall 2012 and it's a very great pleasure
to welcome you all to this core course
lecture by Eric Kandel there are
occasional core lectures such as this
it's a tradition at Columbia but this is
the first time we've had a lecture like
this associated with frontiers of
science
it was inspired by Columbia holding its
first-ever brain month and you might say
well what the heck is brain month it's a
series of events designed to raise
awareness of neuroscience and we are
very fortunate to have with us a
Columbia scientist and author who thinks
deeply and broadly about his field and
who's nobel prize in the year 2000 was
awarded for work on the physiology of
memory before we move on to the lecture
I'd like you to take out your cell
phones and switch them off which is what
I'm now doing we go and it is now a
great pleasure to introduce to have
president introduce the speaker and I'm
going to turn the podium over to Lee
Bollinger Lee's a graduate of Columbia
Law School a leading scholar in the
First Amendment he came to Columbia or
returned to Columbia a decade ago from
the University of Michigan where he was
the president and also the Dean at a law
school he played an important role in
the establishment of what's called the
mind brain behavior initiative which is
soon to move to its new quarters of
Manhattanville and now I'd like to
welcome president Bollinger
well it's a great great pleasure to just
have a few comments to make about Eric
Kandel this is a highly highly dangerous
person and a highly seductive and and
one experiment would be to ask how many
of you will become neuroscientists after
this lecture and you got to be really
careful this truly is a model person for
all of us who work with Eric and for
other people who who get to interact
with him or see him like as a person who
has worked on what he believed in and we
all know he won a Nobel Prize but when
he was working on sea snails and trying
to understand memory I don't think there
was a Nobel Prize in his mind at that
point he was not trying to win a Nobel
Prize and he was doing what he felt was
important and what he believed in and
where his curiosity was taking him and
that was extremely important and it's
exactly what we hope in great
universities that scholars will do and
then over the course of his life he has
continually evolved so it's not doing
the same thing over and over again which
is one of the traps of trying to do
creative work just recently he has
become quite a star and public
television with Charlie Rose and you can
get the DVD of those you probably have
seen some of them but he's also taken
his work and branched out into other
fields of his very capacious interest
and in particular he has become a person
who blended his understanding of
psychology psychiatry neuroscience and
art and in particular the art of
turn-of-the-century
Vienna
where he is from he's also a person have
great principle and here I think it's
worth noting that that he has spoken out
repeatedly and in the most persuasive
and powerful ways about how Austria
treated Jews in World War two and how
the country should react to that for
which he is also been honored but again
he did not do any of that I'm sure for
the prospect of honors he is a fantastic
Columbia citizen a world citizen of
course but a fantastic Columbia citizen
and and Nick mentioned the mind brain
behavior initiative which we started
just maybe nine years ago when the idea
of Manhattanville was was just that only
an idea and we had to have something
that would set the intellectual terms of
the new campus something that would be
special and I asked Eric along with
Richard Axel and Tom Jessel if they
would take on the subject of
neuroscience but broadly the study of
the mind in the brain as all of us do
because it's my belief I think it's a
common belief that we all think about
the mind we all think about the brain
ultimately and was something that was
only a dream for Eric to take that on at
this stage in this stage of his career
and then to be there every step of the
way and now it really will be a reality
just in three-and-a-half years from now
it will open up and will do so much for
Columbia joining the two campuses uptown
and down
town bringing us together from all
different fields this is a great project
and an eric was there at the beginning
willing to take it on he is a person who
is extremely generous to other scholars
to other people in their work and yet he
is also a person who has standards so if
you're not doing well Eric will tell you
but in the nicest possible way
he's extremely tolerant he is a person
who really does believe in difference of
opinion and the virtues of that but he
is a person as well who has his own
beliefs and will defend them so finally
he is one of the greatest people in the
world
and perhaps that's the the most
important of all he has an extraordinary
sense of humor and if you can get him to
laugh just wait for the joy that his
laugh will will bring to you so if
you're looking as a young person for
somebody to become and you should be
look no further than Eric Kandel Eric
don't please lead two things one is I'm
really sorry that my parents are not
here to listen to you
my father would been very proud and my
mother would have believed every single
word but speaking about the mind brain
behavior initiative which you inspired
it turns out that three days ago
principles of neuroscience which is
really obvious textbook of neuroscience
which at this point is the heaviest the
most expensive textbook in the field and
also considered the standard just came
out with his new edition the fifth
edition all the editions done at
Columbia and it is the privilege of the
faculty that built this book
to give it to you
we mentioned how much Columbia owes to
us I think Steve Tom Richard and I who
have been here for some time feel very
strongly it is we who owe Columbia
because we would not have had the kinds
of enjoyable socially interactive and
absolutely productive careers that we've
had if we were not at home yet so I'm
here today to speak about as part of the
frontiers of science program to consider
mine brainy behavior and with in mind of
being behavior I want to focus my
discussion specifically on learning and
memory learning these are you know -
magical capabilities of the mind
learning is the process whereby we
acquire new knowledge about the world
and memory is the process whereby we
retain that information over time most
of the knowledge we have about the world
that most of our skills are not built
into our brain but I learned as a result
of this knowledge both of a lifetime we
are in good measure who we are because
of what we learned in what we remember
my overt specific disorders of learning
and disturbances memory haunt the
developing infant as well as the mature
adult mental retardation affect the
quality of life of young people while
normal weakening of memory with age and
the devastation of Alzheimer's disease
haunt the other memory is the glue that
binds our mental life together without
the unifying force of memory our
consciousness would be broken in as many
fragments as there are seconds in the
day without memory our life would be
empty
it would be meaningless imagine a life
without memory we see this in a tragic
fate of Claude wearing this is a very
gifted pianist and choral conductor who
more than 20 years ago suffering from a
brain
infection herpes encephalitis that is
stored destroyed the part of his brain
that is concerned with memory and made
his life a series of disconnected
fragments here is a person without
memory
that's what we like just like that no
different she did in that sense mean
total pain which is not something which
is just a precise effective never spend
his senses of pain history
I don't remember sitting down on this
chair John 4:13 as it is I was unknown
to me I've never seen him ever since
I've ever seen anybody
my son's in traffic cloud wearing shows
us have memory binds our mental life
together he connects the countless
phenomenon of our existence into a
single hole it is convenient to divide
the study of memory into two parts the
system's problem of memory the question
when the brain is memory stored and the
molecular problem of memory which asked
the question what are the mechanisms
whereby storage occurs in each of these
sites historically the studied memory
began with the first question
where is memory stored
and this was part of a larger question
that is can any mental process be
localized to specific regions of the
brain this is an extremely deep question
and the attempt to solve it affects one
of the great intellectual
accomplishments of brain science in the
nineteenth century the first person to
address it was Franz Joseph gall who did
his major work beginning around 1780 in
Vienna and he made two remarkable
contributions to brain signs that stand
up to this day he argued very
effectively conceptually that all mental
functions are biological and arise from
the brain that is there is no soul this
was not a Cartesian view this was a
unified view that every mental process
from the simplest reflex act to the
highest creative flight of fancy or come
from the brain moreover he thought that
the brain particularly the cerebral
cortex the outer covering of the brain
does not function as the units but that
different functions can be localized the
different regions of the cerebral cortex
now in order to determine where
different functions are localized he
took advantage of the fact that it was a
very good anatomist and knew a lot about
the anatomy of the brain he knew that
there were four lobes frontal temporal
parietal and occipital but he also knew
that there were at least 40 or more
functions that psychologists had
described as critical mental functions
and so for those four lobes alone
couldn't buy themselves explained the
mental functions each lobe must contain
a number of different functions so he
began to assign functions to different
regions of the brain and he went about
this rather systematically he assigned
the cognitive functions such as
causality in comparison to the front of
the brain the sentiments of his hope and
sublimity to the middle of the brain and
instinctual functions like parental love
aggressiveness to the back of the brain
now how did he come about that making
these the silence but one way to do this
would have been to see whether or not I
can correlate particular kinds of mental
processes to different disease states of
the brain but he was suspicious of
patients as being informative for basic
science
he didn't think but one could learn very
much from that but he had a lot of
confidence in his ability as an observer
he was a very astute observer
particularly patients people's heads and
he looked at the heads of the people he
knew his friends and he notice they had
different shapes and he thought this
reflectance underlying capabilities he
thought that each of these 40 odd
functions there to describe serves a
little bit as a muscle that if you use
it a lot if you think a lot about legal
issues then the area concerned with
little issues expands and that causes
the skull above that to rise a little
bit form a bump and you can detect that
with careful observation how did he
reach that observation to begin with
well he was struck with the fact that
the front of the brain is involved with
cognitive function because the really
intelligent people that he knew had very
prominent foreheads this probably got
this idea by going around and looking at
Columbia undergraduates realized how
distinct that they were while the people
who were shallow thinkers had much less
prominent forays and he thought that the
cognitive functions such as comparisons
expanded as a result of using it by the
curriculum of course it'll do it for
anybody similarly in terms of the back
of the brain the instinctual functions
he was struck with the fact that the
women he knew who repeat them to be very
romantic the merry widows of Vienna had
a prominent back of the head and those
that were less romantic had a flat back
of the head and again he thought this
occurred because the emotive enough
reason no man
love expanded in these romantic women
and this gave the back of the head
prominence this idea this whole schema
gave rise to a concept of phrenology
where people went around and explored
each other's heads this caught on all
over Europe with the exception of France
that I'll turn to in a moment
quote on particularly in America
Americans loved it you could not get
married in the United States without the
father of the bride examining if you're
a man your skull and making sure that
you have the appropriate bumps and
didn't have inappropriate bucks the only
people that were skeptical with the
French Marie Jean Pierre Flourens was a
great experiment of neurologists and he
said I don't believe a word of this
daily you know it's very nice
sounds very attractive but what are the
data what are the experience behind this
the man has not done a single experiment
and so Florence didn't experiment he
said if a Mota Venus is this region at
the back of the brain one we remove a
massiveness and experimental animals and
see what it does to the romantic
behavior and remove this cats and dogs
and he saw affected a little bit their
motor skills but had no ability no
effect at all and they capability for
romantic love and he came up with a very
strong statement that mental functions
cannot be localized all perceptions all
Volition's occupy the same seat in these
several organs the Faculty of perceiving
of conceiving of willing nearly
constitute therefore faculty which is
essentially one so he argued mental
functions cannot be localized and he
developed a view which we call I so
potentiality in which you cannot
localize the function the whole cerebral
cortex function is a single units for
the next forty years this was the
dominant view and then a giant appeared
on the scene Pierre Paul Broca a great
French neurologist and anthropologist
and Explorer he actually believed
that goal was probably right even though
his approach was Deborah Wang
he argued that I had thought that if
there were a friend illogical science it
would be phrenology of the convolutions
that is the actual natural regions of
the brain in the cortex and not the
phrenology of bumps on the head but as
you have to look at the brain not at the
skull in the argot the mental functions
can be localized to specific regions of
the brain and he thought he would do
this by trying to look at a particular
disease entity to see where they could
localize it and he focused on disorders
of language which are called aphasia and
he actually had very good fortune of
fortune of encountering a patient by the
name of leborgne
was a result of a stroke developed a
specific aphasia a difficulty with
language and his was a very selective
defect although he understood language
perfectly well he could not express
himself in language he could not speak
now you might think this is a mode of
paralysis of the vocal chords or some
difficulty with the mouth but this is
not the case he could hum a tune
perfectly well and he could whistle and
he could even say a word or two he just
could not speak romantically when the
born died and came to autopsy broke
examined his brain and he found a lesion
in the front of the brain and this put
him in a very awful position he wanted
to discuss it in seminars he wanted to
speak about this region describe it
point out that it's involved in the
expression of language and he didn't
quite have the right terminology front
didn't know what to do with how to call
this region and all modesty he named it
after himself
Broca's it what was the poor man to do
he then examined eight of the patients
that had a very similar a fascia and he
found that invariably it was in the
front of the brain and invariably was in
left hemisphere and he enunciated one of
the great principles of neuroscience
mubalo
of acclaim is fear gosh we speak with a
left hemisphere
this was the first indication that for
most people the left hemisphere is the
dominant hemisphere of the brain this
really got the neuroscientific community
excited people began to explore the
surface of the cortex in great detail
and a few years have to broke up ten
years later at 1870 Fitz in his City two
German scientists began to stimulate an
area right behind Broca's area and
describe what we now call the motor
cortex they stimulated this region that
they found that at different points they
listed at different kinds of movements
it was organized in a very systematic
way there was a monk ulis it was a map
of your body surface on the brain so
first medially you had the face then you
had the arm and then you had the leg so
there was a systematic representation of
your body under surface of the cortex
quite remarkable five years later the
next step was taken by called vertigo a
brilliant physician who at age 20 c6
made a major advance of how we think
about aphasias he encountered a patient
who had an aphasia there was the mid may
add a mirror image of that apropos
Broca's patient could understand but
could not speak while very crisp a
patient could speak but he could not
understand when he died he came to
autopsy Vertica found that he had a
lesion at the back of the brain now
again he wanted to talk about it to
other people he needed to refer to it it
needed to compare to Broca's area so
neither name for it and again in all
modesty he named it after himself Verna
Khazaria but he did more than just named
this area he took advantage of something
which is extremely important in songs
and that is even though he was the
second person to discover language area
he had the advantage of knowing that
another person come before him and
described something which is really
quite instructive I
take advantage of these two piece of
information and I can have a more
complete theory and he developed the
first view of a neural circuit for
language that we have and although this
is a highly simplified view it still
explains about 80% of the phenomenon you
see an emergency clinic when you see a
patient with aphasia he said look it
would be naive to think that complex
functions like language can be
restricted to a single area very simple
perceptual and motor tasks might be
restricted to Sinclair but complex
functions must involve multiple areas
and he was the first one that gave rise
to the fact that there is a distributed
representation of most complex functions
he said complex functions like language
cannot be localized to a single region
but involve interconnections between
several regions distributed processing
was introduced by Veronica he pointed
out that language has separate sentient
motor programs each governed by distinct
regions of the cortex and he thought of
it in the following terms the sensory
region he thought was the area he
described Veronica's area it's of the
back of the brain and that's where
sensory information comes in when you
speak to somebody it activates the audio
auditory cortex
when you read a book it activates the
visual cortex
now both the auditory and visual cortex
project two verticals area so
information language coming in to speech
language coming in through reading are
translated into a neural code and that
neural code converges on Veronica's area
which recognizes it as language
Veronica's area that projects through a
pathway called the arcuate fasciculus to
Broca's area which contains the grammar
of language and look what Broca's area
is located it's at the front of the
brain it's near the part of the motor
strip that is concerned with
vocalization and in fact it connects to
that area this is a remarkable set of
insights which really provided a rather
sophisticated in the standard for
instead of how language is formulated
moreover it made a very profound
prediction he said that some day because
of the distributed nature of the
representation of language some day
somebody would be able to find a type of
aphasia a disorder of language that does
not involve either Broca's area
veronica's area to any of the students
in the audience guess what kind of a
lesion of the brain could cause that yes
arkad fasciculus brilliant if you
disrupt the pathway between the two the
person speaks and he understands but
there's no connection between the two
it's very much like presidential press
conferences in early administrations
information comes in information comes
out but there's no connection between
the two this is where things stood until
the beginning of the 20th century many
mental functions were localized and
shown to involve complex neural circuits
in the brain but when it came to memory
people thought this is too complex a
function to be localized to any simple
system this must be a distributed
function that involves the whole server
cortex and it gained a lot of momentum
because Karl Ashley the great professor
of psychology at Harvard argued very
strongly for this and in those days
Harvard professors were still taken very
seriously
and he based his conclusion on the
following experiment
who taught mice to run mazes and he
found that when he removed the occipital
cortex which provided the visual input
the mice continue to perform rather well
and then he took up more cortex than the
continued to function well and he
finally lost the ability to remember how
to function the maze when he took out a
huge amount of cortex they found that
the deficit for learning amazes related
to the amount of cortex she took out not
where it was located
what he failed to realize is that my son
is extremely plastic that's compensatory
mechanisms so if you take out the visual
cortex the mouse will learn how to
navigate a maze using tactile clues
using proprioceptive codes using
olfactory cues so animals compensate for
this so this did not disprove the fact
that this localization of function but
the real proof so this is going back to
the florins idea of a distributed
function but the real proof that there
was localization of function came from a
great neurosurgeon trained at the
College of Physicians and Surgeons in
the C Wilder Penfield um while the pen
field left Columbia to go to Montreal
and we accept the Montreal Neurological
Institute and they developed a new
procedure of operating on the brain he
was interested in the cerebral cortex he
was interested in removing scar tissue
from the cerebral cortex that resulted
as a result of brain injury getting hit
on the skull various kinds of accidents
and he knew that the brain itself had no
pain receptors so you could touch
surfaces of stimulate surface of the
brain the patient would feel no pain so
all you had to do is get to to the
and you could work on him in an
uninitialized condition so what he did
was he used a local anesthetic he
infused it into the scalp they could
open up the skull expose the brain it
can stimulate any area that he wanted
this was essential because when he
removed some scar tissue we had make
sure he wasn't managing brokers an area
of very close area or some other area
that is critical to language or other
central functions and as he went around
stimulating different parts of the brain
he found amazingly that when he
stimulated these regions in the temporal
lobe he listed is things that sounded
very much like memory so one patient
would say oh my god I hear a song that
it's very much like the song that they
sang when we graduated from high school
another patient would say I hear my
mother talking to me or third patient
would say I remember experiences in a
football game and this suggested to
Penfield that he had identified a
critical region involved in memory
storage no one had seen anything like
this before and as usual the scientific
community said nice but we're not
convinced but the convincing experiment
which is walking waiting with the
phrases the convincing evidence came a
few years later when it is searched by
the name of William Scofield he counted
a patient by the name of age 10 whose
name we now know as Henry Mollison who
when he was 16 years old was knocked
over while he was riding a bicycle and
he had a bilateral concussion of the
temporal lobe this is the area that
painful
founders involved the money this gave
rise to seizure activity which was well
controlled with anticonvulsants as
result he was able to finish a Memory
school at high school able to enter the
workforce but after while the seizures
became so severe that he felt that he
really needed more sense of treatment
and he went to school build it was a
great neurosurgeon influenced by Penn
field and Scoville operated on him and
he took out the temporal lobe which
contained the full side of the CC star
and he took it out on both sides because
he had a bilateral skull and as a result
of that so this only shows this is a
normal medial temporal lobe the area
with the hippocampus is and this is a
patient HM this has been clearly removed
after this operation HM was without
seizure is controlled throughout the
rest of his life with minor
anticonvulsant medication but as a
result of this yet the most fantastic
memory loss you could possibly imagine
Stover was extremely upset he called up
Enfield and Panvel said oh this is
tragic but we can learn something from
it let me send Brenda Milner was a
terrific psychologist that I've been
working with and that spender can
examine hm and we could learn something
from this and never make these kinds of
mistakes again bender Bella examined him
and found that he had a tremendous
memory deficit but she was an extremely
skilled psychologist and you'll see this
time and time again and what struck her
is how much memory function he actually
retained so for example memories that
occurred prior to the surgical procedure
you know the awkwardness of adolescence
that childhood trauma all those things
you remember perfectly well so really
long-term memories are stored elsewhere
they're not
stored in the hippocampus he had
perfectly good short-term memory so if
we gave him a telephone number in a four
or five four four seven he could be
repeated remember it for a few seconds
so short-term memory is not stored in
the hippocampus of million when left and
we left severely was he could not
convert new short-term memory into new
long-term memories and this indicated
that the per campus in the medial
temporal lobe has as his function to
convert new short-term memory to the new
long-term memory for many years and
bender work with him for food about
twenty years old told keep working with
him for ten or fifteen years
and she thought this applied to all
areas of knowledge and then she made
another remarkable experiment discovered
she found that he could learn new motor
tasks and the way she discovered this is
should happen do a motor task which was
the father he had to follow the outlines
of the star not looking at his hand not
looking at the pence at his pencil but
looking at a mirror so to learn all the
DaVinci life and this is really quite
difficult to do but he was able to do
quite well
so on the first day and Monday he made a
number of errors at the beginning but he
got progressively better over ten trials
came back and Tuesday much better
performance and he proved a tiny bit
more and the third day he was perfect
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Wednesday was
perfect
this is as good as anybody in your class
can do when we asked them hm how come
you're doing so much better on Wednesday
then you did a Monday you'll say what
are you talking about I've never done
this before in my life such remarkable
he was completely unaware that he had
mastered this this is exactly what you
will see with fiber
I'm sorry
the sound is not coming up anyway Clive
wearing plays the piano plays it as well
as he did before the Opera before you
had it surfaces up you asked him
afterwards how do you feel he said I
don't remember dog thing how do you feel
when you're playing the piano this is
what are you talking about I have to
play the count for decades he is
completely unaware of the fact that he
had just played the piano and this
happens with a number of issues and this
is interesting for several reasons it
makes us realise that there are certain
kinds of memories memory how to play the
piano he could conduct a choral group
and when he sat down he didn't remember
that he conducted the choral group there
are certain kinds of memories that are
unconscious and it makes us aware as we
now you know keenly know that amazing
amount of our mental life is unconscious
on this point for it was absolutely
right it also made us realize that
memory is not a unitary function of mind
but has a least two forms it conscious
form and the unconscious form the
unconscious form we call implicit memory
it's a memory for motor and perceptual
skills hitting it back hand riding a
bicycle if you ride a bicycle after
you've mastered it you don't tell
yourself put your left foot forward put
your right foot forward if you talk to
yourself like that you'll fall off the
bicycle so you first learn to paying
attention but after a while becomes
automatic the same with many aspects of
driving this is in contrast to explicit
memory which is memory for facts and
events which involves the medial
temporal lobe and the structure deep to
it it's called epic campus which is
central central fluid and while implicit
memory does not require conscious
participation because unconsciously we
call explicit memory requires conscious
recall moreover they involve different
systems as you saw explicit memory
involves at the campus implicit memory
involves a number of
instructors in the brain the amygdala
for emotional memory sir golem for motor
memories and simplest reflex pathway for
themselves four very simple big presses
so that really sort of brings us to the
second topic given the fact that there
are two major memory systems in the
brain implicit explicit one of the
molecular mechanisms of each of these do
they share any features in common or
they completely different now they have
clear differences implicit explicit
memory the nature of the knowledge
stored as we saw the sexual and motor
skills and one hand facts and events of
the other the site of storage in
implicit memories the reflex pathways
and cerebellum in explicit memories that
the campus in the temporal lobe and
finally implicit memory reflex after our
conscious versus men before the events
in your life involve conscious recall
explicitly question is do they share
features in common despite these
differences and if so can molecular
biology help reveal the universal
features of them now there are three
features actually in common one is in
both implicit explicit memory there are
two separate components there's a
short-term memory which lasts minutes
and a long-term component which can last
days weeks and even for lifetime if an
end
number one number two we know how to
move information from short-term to
long-term and that is repetition
practice makes perfect
in both implicit explicit memory as it
does for undergraduates and as it does
for us everyone and finally long-term
memory differs in short-term memory
because it requires the synthesis of new
performance this has been known for some
time we now know as I was shown that the
media requires the synthesis of new
proteins is because it differs
fundamentally from short-term memory
involves turning on genes that give rise
to new protein synthesis there are a
number of different experimental systems
have been used to study implicit
explicit memory I'm just going to focus
in two of them I'm going to focus in the
snail of up to look at implicit
memory because that the top require
conscious attention and I'm going to use
the mouse to describe expressive memory
because mice have attention we normally
have consciousness that they certainly
look up there I'm going to begin with
implicit memory and the prison focus on
learn fear is studied by process called
sensitization explicit memory I'm going
to look at memory in space which is
critically involved in the campus so
this is a pretty California snail this
is a highly beautiful animal this sort
of animal all of you which work on if
you interested in studying in prison
memory storage this atom was not only
beautiful and it has the appearance of
being highly intelligent but it's
extraordinarily accomplished in fact the
many people in the world
that think that the snail is the only
person that really deserved what are the
advantages of studying a why would
one want to do that well your brain in
mind is a hundred billion neurons that's
a lot of nerve cells difficult to study
you want to take a complex problem you
sometimes better off looking at it in
its simplest representation the ecclesia
brain only has 20,000 neurons mova the
nervous system is beautifully organized
it is set up in terms of ganglia 10
ganglia each of them contains 2,000 of
ourselves
so the whole nervous system only has
20,000 dollars more over a single
ganglion containing 2,000 their cells
can mediate not one but a whole family
of different behaviors so the number of
cells committed to a single baby can be
quite small a hundred nerve cells for
even less moreover the rhesus one
doesn't quite understand pleasure has
the largest nerve cells in the animal
kingdom they're truly gigantic before
became Presby object I could see them
with my naked up there a millimeter in
diameter not only that their distinctive
in their position and the location
should give them specific numbers and
letters and return to the same cell in
every animal of the species so you can
work out a neural circuit of the
behavior in terms of specific identified
cells in this simple animal with the
central nervous system we studied an
extremely simple reflex to give birth to
all these place this is a dorsal view of
an animal it has an external respiratory
organ an external lung if you will call
the Gill this is covered for protection
by a sheet of skin called the
mantelshelf which ends in a fleshy spout
called the siphon
if you apply a weak tactile stimulus of
the siphon you get it very nice
withdrawal it again this is like the
withdrawal of a hand from a hot object
if you're now scared the animal giving
it a shock to the tail
the same week stimulus to the siphon but
is a much more powerful withdrawal
author Gil now this skill withdrawal
reflex could say lasts only seconds but
the memory of the offending stimulus can
last for minutes two days depending upon
number of repetitions if you give a
single tail shock produce a short-term
memory and that lasts for half an hour
so if you can 5vp detail shots you
produce a long-term memory the last a
circle that is more over here as in
other systems one of the characteristic
features of long-term memory its
selectively sensitive in evidence of
protein sensitivities so if you give the
animal protein synthesis inhibitor it
has perfectly good short-term memory but
you'll wipe out its ability for long
term one can work out the neural circuit
of this behavior the siphon is innovated
by 24 sensory neurons
it makes direct connections to six motor
neurons and these make direct
connections to the guild so you have a
direct pathway since you're into motor
neuron together there are some in
Turners both inhibitory and excitatory
but they have a relatively minor role
what happens when you stimulate the tail
when you simulate the table you activate
a modulator system that uses certain as
its transmitter so as you know that you
have in your brain a whole range of
modulatory transmitters certain energy
dopaminergic cholinergic that are very
important for different mood States for
arousal for fear for pleasure these
certain Ettrick cells end on the sensory
nerves including on the presynaptic
terminal and their serotonin acts to
strengthen the connector
between the center and the modern and
the critical event in learning is if you
strengthen specific synaptic connections
in the brain if you give a single tail
shot we produce a transient
strengthening which is functional you
don't see any anatomical change and I'll
tell you in a moment how this comes
about if you've repeated tail shock you
actually caused a growth of new synaptic
connections so if you remember anything
about this lecture and I don't urge it
on you
but if you remember anything of this
lecture tomorrow it is because your
brain will have been change the result
of the experience of being here she'll
have a slightly different brain that you
came into the structure look how can we
study this in greater detail well one of
the characters that leaves what does in
science is to take a reductionist
approach to see whether this system
which is very simple can be simplified
even more one can take a single sensory
earn a single motor neuron a single
serve serve it yourself and put it into
the Associated self culture so you just
have three cells in fact since we know
that the certain allergic cell releases
serotonin we can simply use a pipette
and puff on serotonin if we puff on
serotonin once we get a transient
strengthening of synaptic connections
just like we see with the attack
behavior and if you puff it on five
times you get a more enduring
facilitation that lasts for a couple of
days my over this facilitation as the
behavior requires new protein synthesis
if you block protein synthesis
you have the short-term facilitation but
no effect at all of long-term
facilitation one of the market mechanics
that underlie this this is a sensory
neuron this is the motor neuron this is
the tail and
yourself when you stimulate the table
you activate these certain symmetric
cells and they release a transmitter
serotonin so stimulate the tail and the
search erratic cells release a
transmitter serotonin this acts on a
receptive to a third common in the
sensory neuron that activates an enzyme
that causes an increase in intracellular
messenger called cyclic AP that
activates an enzyme called the cyclic AP
dependent protein kinase and that acts
in the presynaptic terminal of the
neuron the contact points it releases a
chemical substance whereby the sensor
node communicates with the motor neuron
that chemical substance is carried in
little containers little vesicles and
what allows the release of those
vesicles is an influx of ions calcium
ions and the cyclic GMP dependent
protein kinase leads to an increase in
calcium influx and therefore two more
transmitters if you give repeated
stimuli something fascinating happens
you release more serotonin you activate
more of the enzyme that increases like
the KP you activate the cyclic AMP II
dependent protein kinase for long a pair
of common and as result of that it not
only acts in the presynaptic terminal to
enhance transmitter release it actually
translocates into the nucleus and in so
doing it the Cootes another kinase and
together they activate genes you
activate two kinds of factors that act
on genes active a
CREB one which is a gene activator and
you also remove an inhibitory constraint
in creve one quad CREP - why would you
want to have an inhibitory constraint
than wrong to remember can anybody in
the audience one of the studios guess
what do we want to put everything into
long-term memory do you want to have
inhibitor constraints on long-term
memory yes your maybe brain is filled
with garbage looked a lot of lectures he
listened to that are boring you wonder
forgive me I'm not suggesting you
remember sex you may want to forget it
opinion a lot of things that happen to
you are unimportant memory has to reach
a certain threshold for you to put into
long-term memory because once you do
that you undergo structural change which
can persist for some period power now
the structure of change and approach is
really quite profound this is a
controlled sensory neuron and a control
motor neuron and after long term
sensitization you have an increase in
contacts between the sensor and the
motor nerve is quite traumatic
you have 1,200 synapses between a
sensory neuron and the motor learn
before learning in twenty eight hundred
afternoon this is not unique to
appreciate this also holds for you and
me I told you before about the motor
cortex you could modify the strength of
connections and actually the size of
regions within the motor cortex by motor
practice for example if you examine the
hand representation of people who play
the violin you find that the right hand
that does the bowing is the same in
violin players as it is in anyone
because the figures are not
differentiated but the left-handed does
the fingering is much larger in violent
players than it isn't people who don't
play and if you did what your mother
told you to and that is you sort of
paint early in life your representation
of the hand area would be much larger
than if you started later on what about
explicit memory to what degree does it
bear similarities in the molecular level
to what degree differences here the key
work has been done with the mouse
we know the hippocampus is involved in
memory from hm on many of the studies
and one particular complex sense
modality that is very well represented
in the hippocampus is space and both in
people and in mouse mice memory for
space has been studied extensively and
you can see this beautifully in humans
by looking at London taxi drivers and
just what can testify to this unlike New
York taxi drivers to have the foggiest
notion with Morningside Heights is a
London taxi driver has to take extensive
the examinations before can qualified to
be certified taxi driver and the Lord a
browser taxi the logic is hippocampus
becomes so people have been driving for
several years of the substantially large
epic campus and do other people moreover
once they stop driving it a taxicab
hippocampus begins to shrink down this
is true in people in mice as well you
can give my stance for example this is
called the Barnes maze I'm gonna come
back to this repeatedly in which you put
a mouse into the centre of this platform
there are 40 holes and you shine light
on it the mouse does not like the
attention that's like the spotlight of
this like the music wants to get away
from that so the only we can do that is
to find the
whole that leads to the skinny patch at
first it does random guesses and then it
follows a serial pattern but ultimately
learns aha the hole is in relationship
to that marking on the wall and boom
efforts learn that you can do that very
rapidly the neural circuit for space is
really quite complicated space is not a
single modality it involves visual
tactile proprioceptive olfactory cues
this is what Lashley failed to realize
that it goes into association cortex and
ultimately leads to the internal cortex
the inputs of the hippocampus this is
also the first region that is disturbed
in Alzheimer's disease internal cortex
fields of the hippocampus and this is
the epic amasa simply indicates sub
regions the details of which are for the
moment under corporate food every one of
these sub regions undergoes a change in
synaptic strength if you're stimulated
artificially and you can test for that
to see whether it has synaptic
plasticity of the described of the kind
of describe to you in duplicity by
simply giving trains of stimuli to any
one of these pathways a common pathway
that is used is one of the output
pathways called the Schaffer common
pathway if you give a single stimulus
you produce a transient facilitation the
last a couple of hours but if you give
repeated stimuli then long-term
facilitation for the last two days
can anyone in the audience predict what
is the fundamental difference between
those long-term facilitation is
short-term from starvation
what will the long-term facilitation
required that the short end is not
new protein synthesis and we can see now
exactly how this happens if you
stimulate the Schaffer collateral
benefit you activate it in the
postsynaptic cell a pathway that is
differently for short term memory will
activated in implicit memory storage it
involves a different enzyme not the
cyclic AMP II dependent protein kinase
but involves cam kinase but it leads to
a similar change in synaptic strength
similar kind of synaptic plasticity but
if you give repeated stimuli you have
more calcium influx but you also recruit
a modular toy transmitter in parallel to
serotonin this is dopamine and dopamine
activates the cyclic AMP II system
cyclic ap dependent protein kinase
activates Craig and gives rise to the
growth of you synaptic connectors so
even though short-term memory is
different the process involved in
long-term memory are amazingly conserved
we can ask in our nice question we can
do genetic tests in mice you can see
what happens when we knock out the
cyclic AMP II dependent protein kinase
do we interfere with the leg phase of
the synaptic potentiation called long
term potentiation do we affect long term
memory
we can express this specifically in the
hippocampus and we can see that the
short-term facilitation is a wild-type
and two mutants that have pk knocked out
it's no way affected but the long term
is significantly compromised Africa
memory we see wild types the mutants
memory is severely compromised so
despite the fact that implicit and
explicit memory are very very different
they share features and comments that
people as far as long-term memory
involved the short-term memory process
is conceptually similar but molecular
details that
but the long-term process invariably
involves turning on genes
creping a critical player both in
implicit explicit memory leading to the
growth of new synaptic connections in
both cases now one of the reasons this
is interesting and this is what I want
to end with is that these basic science
insights can be useful in giving us an
early understanding of some disorders of
memory and one thing that has been
studying some detail is memory decline
with age there are two major kinds of
memory decline with age
one is normal weakening of memory with
age which is called age-related memory
loss or benign senescent forgetfulness
and the other is the early Alzheimer's
disease which they can progress to
full-blown Alzheimer's disease let me
begin with age-related memory loss mice
do not spontaneous them to go waltz on
this disease but they do show
age-related memory loss so if you show
them the spawns maze which I showed
before they do very well when the early
early until middle age they do really
quite well to limit to be about two
years old but when they get to be twelve
months you begin to see a significant
drop-off if you now look at the synaptic
facilitation you see these are the young
mice if completely normal facilitation
and the old mice do not notice that the
short-term facilitation is not impaired
and give us this is exactly as you saw
when you PU you interfere with cyclic
AMP
cyclicamp independent protein callus so
this suggested of evidence support of it
that one of the defects in age-related
memory loss is an impairment of cyclic
ap Sigma so if that's so and we have an
insight into it can we overcome that can
we reverse age related memory loss well
one way to do it is to see whether we
give dopamine this march of the toy
transmitter in fact we find if we give
dopamine we can take the age rate of
memory loss and reverse it and make you
just like an adolescent moreover you can
interfere different points not only by
giving more dopamine here but preventing
the breakdown of cyclic game P there's
an enzyme called cyclic a dependant
phosphorus race if you inhibit that but
the drug called roller pram you do
exactly the same thing other studies
have gone on beyond that to show that
there's a modulate of crema that also is
interfered with and you can overcome it
by altering its level expression that
brings me the final point which is
really a very interesting for the sort
of preliminary observation made by
Michael shlonsky at the head of
pathology at Columbia he was interested
in Alzheimer's disease and Alzheimer's
disease is due to the deep position of
plaques in the brain and extracellular
change there were also some
intracellular change that I'm going to
draw that the major change is a toxic
product is produced that ultimately
forms plaques this toxic product is due
to at a peptide that's released from the
cell membrane called the a beta pep talk
and if it first
floats around outside the cell but
ultimately forms plaques people notice
that even when it floats around before
it forms plaques it's toxic to the cell
and it's toxic the synthesis and she
Lance gassed himself why is this the
soluble form already toxic to the cell
and he found that what happens with it
is it shuts down the cyclic ap system so
when he gives Rollo prayer and allows
the cyclic AMP II system to be serviced
or to more normal function he can
restore the growth and he can store
normal synaptic transmission so he went
to mice that actually had an expression
of the Alzheimer gene produced a mild
form of Alzheimer's disease and he saw
that in the early stages there was a
loss of synaptic connections but the
role of pram could restore it there was
a loss of memory and that role of M
could restore now I'm not showing this
to tell you that we have cures for
Alzheimer's disease what we have truest
and age-related memory loss we're very
very early stages to understand all of
this and the initial approach to
Alzheimer's disease has taken a very
different direction
my more productive direction of problems
is I simply want to tell you how
important animal models are allowing you
to explore mechanisms of memory and even
to study ways of reversing that by
developing drugs by using these assets
so we've gotten some preliminary
insights using animal models into both
benign senescence forgetfulness and
early stages of Alzheimer's disease so
let me conclude by saying that we've
come a long way since Franz Joseph oh
thank god we've gone from distributed
localization of complex behavior to
systems to molecules and one of the
things that the mind great behavior
initiative hopes to do is to take
advantage of the 21st century the
century of the mind to develop a new
biological science of mind
I must say Lee Bolin just put us in an
office position to do just that so thank
you very much and I'll just show you my
colleagues are responsible for the work
yang you want a table Mary Elizabeth
Bachmann's Oh mark barrage booster butch
Elan ce qu'il Merritt pretty volleyball
and B were complicit and really working
the mouse and the stuff that I showed
you to Alzheimer's disease with them
about hobby rapture and excellency
obviously all the earlier work was done
before I was even born
thank you
I'd be glad to answer any questions that
you have
yes
you know you're asking a wonderful
question which is a very sophisticated
question and it's number like asking why
do you and I prefer we you know have a
large number of differences in our
brains and if you look at any attributes
you'll find do slightly different
strategies part of this is determined by
genetic predisposition part of it's
determined by the kinds of things we're
interested in is we evolved as human
beings so if you develop mathematical
interest as you went along it's much
easier for you to be able to handle
mathematical equation to do that than
somebody who has something certain
really so these factors both
environmental experiences as well as
genetic predisposition vary for all of
them
mental traits that you couldn't think
that but certainly practice for example
no one has any insight really profound
insight to how to prevent Alzheimer's
disease or a traumatic memories there is
now some you know increasingly good
evidence that certain things are
protective at least for age-related
memory loss so this will apply to most
people and that is being physically
healthy now
no diabetes under control getting high
blood pressure and for good diet good
physical exercise also being socially
engaged in being intellectually
convinced
Linda food has done a wonderful study
she's followed a series of people in the
in their seventies women and she asked
them to help out in schools this is the
Dean of the scoop of the topic coffee
and it's to help kids to read so what
they did is essentially
and give reading exercises to kids at
school
they found that the woman's intellectual
performance was better maintained they
were involved in activities like this
that they were not involved in any so
being intellectually active it's
extremely important label offices at all
phases of life there's somebody right
behind me
we take lately I've noticed that you are
making a lot of art critique you know
and you are like open it the
neuroscience how is the art were
receiving that critique and if you think
that you are taking away from the pure
act of admiring art can you repeat the
question both I mean some people are
responding very positively to it there
are people who get upset
what is the biologist doing in the
domain avoidance and this actually held
true for Neuroscience moving into many
areas before there is a view that
because we're scientists and we
reductionists this is going to be
eliminated productions we're gonna come
along and we're gonna say you know
artists fears no merely and instead of
caps no meaning until we come along and
give you the ultimate truth and you
really won't understand that's nonsense
we think that this is a parallel insight
your own response to it is extremely
important but just like if you you know
you see a play by Shakespeare you are
either played by Gertie reading a
commentary can sometimes enlighten you I
see your biological insights is giving
you additional insights for example why
our Expressionists artists so effective
but it's interesting to know first of
all that they work a lot with faces and
we have a huge representation of faces
in the brain moreover if you look at
individual cells and the face patches of
the brain they respond dramatically to
exaggeration and this is why you respond
so dramatically to cartoons you
recognize people better a cartoon of
Nixon is better than a photograph of
Nixon on many levels
and artists intuitive this and used
exaggeration unnatural colors you know
bringing the eyes further apart closer
together in order to bring out emotional
feelings I don't know what any of you
have seen Messerschmitts head sculptures
they're fantastic for doing that but we
now have some insight into why this
occurs we also know that the brain is a
creativity machine that when you look at
a painting you are undergoing an
experience that is a modest form a
recapitulation of what the artist does
and that is you have to reconstruct that
information your sensory system does not
work as a photographic plate it
reconstructs the information from the
outside world puts it together and then
if it really has a top-down process that
compares it to other images it seems
other experiences you've had
so that really merges to give you your
response to it and that's why you are
not looking at the same painting that is
somewhat different response to it
because we've undergoing slightly
different creative processes and you can
trick the brain and show that it is
doing reconstruction by showing
illusions of various kinds which the
brain will make errors on because you
quote the technique that the brain used
for putting the image together you play
with it so I see this as a parallel
process not in any way to attract other
approaches to visual aesthetics
so there are people who remember every
detail of their lives and so for these
people would you say that their brains
are in a constant metamorphosis and for
us like average people would you say how
how how fast would you say that that our
brains are changing clearly when the
synapses change in your brain there's
nothing comparable to what we're seeing
in a vision right it's a much simpler
system and as fewer cells in order to
carry out behavioral tasks it has to the
individual cells have to go undergo more
dramatic changes that if you have a lot
of cells carrying out this task in fact
what has to say that the evidence that
this synapses per se changing in a human
is an inference from seeing that the
regions change okay but we certainly see
in mice and other higher animals exactly
the same kind of changes and this is
really not surprising in the sense that
you want to strengthen connections for
things that are important for things
that you practice and you do a very
loyal does that answer your question
how long do you think it will be before
your research has trickled down into the
field of medicine let's say
so how would be applied to medicine okay
so let me make two statements about that
that's a wonderful question
one is I thought you were gonna say how
long will it be before the mind brain
behavior initiative has a complete
understanding of the human body and that
I must tell you is a very but practical
problems in medicine
I think that's happening all the time
let me give you some examples I came
into neuroscience in the back door I was
interested in psychoanalysis and I left
psychoanalysis and moved into brain
because I found I loved doing brain
signs and the psychoanalysis was not
empirical and it you know didn't seem to
be heading in that direction at all now
we're in a position in which one can
really develop an empirical
psychoanalysis and I'll tell you why in
what we call Helen Mae Berg who turns
out to be a neurologist not a
psychiatrist neurologist who trained at
Columbia by the way image people who are
depressed and she's found a particular
area in the brain in the front part of
the brain called area 25 is hyperactive
in people who are depressed and she
found that if and only if they respond
effectively to psychotherapy this is
cognitive behavior therapy to Jeon Beck
development that abnormalities reversed
the same thing happens if they get
antidepressant medication if they
respond to it that's reversible that's
marvelous so we have a rare case of a
biological marker for mental illness
now we can now use in order to send this
University let me go on she did
something which is fantastic a large
number people don't respond to any kind
of therapy depression so people at
showing parkinson's disease that you can
stop the tremor by stimulating an area
called the subthalamic nucleus which is
critically involved in producing that if
you simulated high frequencies but
essentially shut off the Miche so she
got the idea that maybe people don't
respond to this she can shut this
hyperexcitability off by collaborating
with the neurosurgeon who would do this
deep brain stimulation and she's only
got a small sample but it looks very
encouraging so here is an area in which
we were really in the dark i mean we
would have never we were hoping
something like this would come on in
which was beginning to make progress
so in neurology this spectacular purpose
for evening psychiatry are beginning to
understand things and it we I think
despite the fact that this promise has
been made repeatedly if you look at
things like Alzheimer's disease an
age-related memory loss there's no
question in my mind that in ten years
we're going to begin to have some really
useful treatments for that there are so
many promising avenues despite the
disappointments in the past that are
opening up that if there's adequate
support for science this is not to say
that animal studies are the only way to
solve clinical problems but they're
extremely useful when they've been if
not only in brain science and all eras
I'd like to thank Eric for versatility
major that built very much on what we
did in frontiers of science and brain
behavior it was a fantastic extension of
that I'd like to thank Lee Bollinger for
the introduction and I like the fact
that students for coming and
particularly the students who asked some
excellent questions thank you very much
indeed